now this isn't normally the kind of
video that I make and with the amount of
fake photographs of ghosts and specters
floating around the Internet it's
something I'm always very skeptical of
however with this one being very
personal it's something I feel like I
have to share so my mother lives in a
house Queen Northumberland after
marrying my stepdad the manor dates back
to the 16th century and is located in
the centre of a huge plot of land the
grounds have a church and graveyard on
it and it is the final resting place of
Oliver Cromwell basically the entire
location is steeped in history the house
itself has three floors on it with the
upper floor pretty much being
uninhabited after my stepfather's
doorway moved out recently my wife and I
went up on Boxing Day and decided to
have a look upstairs after hearing from
my sister that she'd heard people
walking around up there when she stayed
over one night we loved ghosts
documentaries and thought this would be
a great fun place to look
needless to say we weren't disappointed
when going into one of the rooms and
discovering a creepy clown doll hanging
up in the middle bar that though that
didn't seem to be anything Supernatural
about the place recently though my
mother was going for a walk around the
house and thought she saw someone
standing in one of the attic windows so
she grabbed her phone and took the
following photo our mum is as skeptical
as I am but after sending us this photo
it's pretty clear to me that there is
someone standing there I have absolutely
no idea who this is and he looks nothing
like my stepfather and we don't have any
family members that this could be no one
from the family recognises the figure
and this kind of thing isn't something
that my mother would stage or try to
fake as you can see from the image we've
not tried a photoshop a doctorate or
change it and it's really freaked
everyone out I've shown it to obviously
if you have any theories or plausible
explanations for the photograph I'd love
to hear it as we're all kind of coming
up with our own theories please leave
them in the comments below and make sure
you subscribe to the channel as I will
probably be picking up on this story
when we've had it
probably lived in two thanks for taking
the time to watch this I hope I haven't
freaked you out too much and if you have
any other similar stories there make
sure you let me know if you'd like to
use this photograph in your own videos
then please get in touch as I've left my
email address in the description
I've been definition please don't have
nightmares and I'll see you next time
take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]